hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today's video is going to be about the
armor and the weapons of the new
character warmonger make sure to watch
the one beforehand as we cover the
emotes signatures and executions and the
like of the character and i feel like
you guys would like to see that
on top of other things you might like to
know there are two things
one there will be no male armor shown in
this video as
warmonger is gender locked as female
meaning you can only play as a female
character
like peacekeeper and nobushi and two
that warmonger has
alternate armor basically warmonger has
10 armor variants and 10
separate alternate armor variations you
can tell that they're the alternate
versions as they say alternate in the
name
they're small modifications made to the
armor like removing antlers and the such
generally of the alternate version will
remove things so keep that in mind
and remember this only has to do with
armor there are no alternate variations
of the weapons
and as always i'll make sure to name the
armors of which is which
in the video so that you aren't confused
same with the weapons and any star
weapons will have an asterisk next to
the name
able to always indicate that it is a
star weapon and the default loadout will
of course just say the word default
underneath it
and finally there will be timestamps in
the description if you want to skip to a
specific part
as we're going to be starting with the
armor first
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
you